Freunde der Sonne,
wie ihr seht stehe ich nicht
vor meiner weißen Wand - hehehe -
und das hier ist auch nicht
das geplante Video
zu Machiavellismus.
Für alle, die es verpasst haben,
wir machen hier auf dem Kanal
eine kleine Serie
zur Dunklen Triade, den dunklen,
bösen Eigenschaften, die allen
von uns innewohnen sollen.
Teil 1 zu Narzismus kam vor 2 Wochen
und kam ziemlich gut bei euch an,
ihr dunklen Seelen.
Ihr habt Hashtags gebildet,
ihr wolltet wissen,
wann es weitergeht
mit Machiavellismus.
Und ich sagte: heute.
Leider ist Melanie, unsere tolle,
liebe Grafikerin, krank
und wir haben das Video
deswegen nicht ganz fertig bekommen.
Oh, he,
was ganz wichtiges vergessen.
Leute, heute ist nicht mein Tag,
bzw., es ist nicht unsere Woche,
ich hab hier nämlich gerade
die Soundmachine rausgeholt
und wollte hier so ein kleines
"Quak, Quak, Quak"
an dieser Stelle einspielen.
Aber anscheinend ist die Batterie
leer und ich habe keine neuen.
Jedenfalls, das ist der Nachteil
von einem kleinen Team,
man ist zwar einerseits schnell
und flexibel aber wenn mal einer
von zweien ausfällt,
dann have we the salad, ne?
Aber dann nutze ich die Zeit
doch mal, um etwas zu tun,
was ich schon länger mal tun wollte,
nämlich: Kommentare kommentieren!
Und jetzt würde ich
so ein "Yeah!"-Applaus machen. Naja.
Onkelxam hat ein Tipp
gegen das Überfressen.
Gurken und Möhren naschen,
Gurken und Möhre statt Chips,
nee, nee, ich glaub, da hast du
was falsch verstanden, ich glaub,
es funktioniert nicht.
Anne Peter schreibt:
Liebe Anne, das würde ich gerne,
aber ich kann nicht,
weil wir sind hier
bei Funk und das wäre Werbung.
Aber wenn ich irgendwann
mal ganz groß werde auf YouTube,
dann lass ich hier alles stehen und
liegen und mache nur noch RoI's.
Nein. Aber wenn ich mal "The Secret
Lab of Science" wieder belebe,
was ich zumindest vorhabe
in den nächsten Monaten,
wenn ich hoffentlich
ein bisschen mehr Zeit habe,
werde ich ja dort früher oder später
auch die selben Klamotten anziehen
und dann kannst du mich
da noch mal fragen.
Apropos dieselben,
Romanski möchte wissen:
Ganz einfach: wenn wir beide die
gleichen Chips essen, bedeutet das,
wir essen die Chips
derselben Sorte und Marke.
Aber wenn wir dieselben Chips essen,
dann müsstest du schon hierher
kommen und mit mir die Chips essen.
Bzw. eigentlich, wenn man es ganz
genau nehmen würde,
müsste einer die Chips essen,
sie erbrechen,
und der andere würde dann...
Julika7 schreibt
zum Erkältungsvideo:
Die Erkältungszeit ist zwar vorbei,
hoffentlich, aber bitte nicht
in die Hand husten oder niesen.
Sondern in den Ellenbogen.
Hatschi!
Denn Hände sind natürlich
die allerbesten Virenverteiler.
Ne?
Deswegen sollte man auch
niemals Ellenbogen lecken.
Das betrifft nicht nur die eigenen.
Stuffkat nuss, wie Muskatnuss, nee:
Vielen lieben Dank, ich weiß es auch
nicht, warte, ich frag mal Melanie.
(Telefon tutet)
- Hallo?
Hallo.
Na, wie geht's dir?
- Mhmh.
Du, ich nehme gerade
das Video auf, ich dachte,
vielleicht willst du
auch dabei sein.
Hier fragt nämlich jemand, wieso wir
nicht mehr Abonnenten haben.
- Wir wissen das auch nicht.
Wir wünschen uns mehr davon.
Ja, falls jemand von euch da draußen
uns gerne guckt aber einfach
zu faul ist, sich ein Account
zu machen, um zu abonnieren,
ich kann es nur empfehlen.
Heldenfussel schreibt
zu dem "Fake News Video",
warum Fakten unsere Meinung
nicht beeinflussen:
Thats the spirit!
Theresa fragt:
Zufällig schon.
Für diejenigen, die das
nicht kennen, ein Science Slam
ist sowas wie ein Poetry Slam,
nur mit Forschung statt mit Poesie.
Ich hab da schon ein paar Mal
mitgemacht in den letzten Jahren,
in letzter Zeit
nicht mehr allzu oft,
weil ich nicht mehr
allzu viel Zeit habe.
Aber wenn ihr mich mal auf der Bühne
in Action sehen wollt,
verlink ich euch ein Science Slam
von mir unten in der Infobox.
Zohan MacAllister fragt:
Das bezog sich darauf, dass ich
bei "Auf Klo" aufgehört habe.
Auf Klo ist ein Talkformat
für 13 bis 17-jährige Mädels
und alle anderen,
die sich gerne anhören,
was 2 Mädels auf dem Klo
zu berreden haben.
Klingt komisch, ist aber ganz cool.
Auf Klo gehört auch zum Funk-Kosmos,
schaut da mal gerne vorbei.
Wie gesagt, ich musste aufhören,
weil ich leider
keine Zeit mehr habe.
Wie vielleicht manche wissen,
bin ich ziemlich busy,
weil ich mach
nicht nur "schönschlau",
das ist mein Hauptding, aber,
wie ich vorhin schon gesagt hab,
ich hab eigentlich
noch meinen eigenen Kanal,
auf dem ich gerne mal wieder
was machen würde.
Dann bin ich bei "Terra X Lesch &
Co" neues Mitglied des "Co's"
und ich bin jetzt
bei einem neuen Funk-Format dabei,
und zwar bei "Musste wissen".
"Musste wissen" ist, wenn man
so will, eine Art Nachhilfeformat,
die Fächer Deutsch, Geschichte und
- Chemie, das bin ich,
sind diese Woche online gegangen
und Physik und Mathe folgen noch.
*Musik*
Der stolze Atheist schreibt zu
"Warum wir auf
Fake News reinfallen":
SJW-Bullschicht? SJW?
Saure-Joghurt-Wurst?
Statistisches-Jugend-Wetter? Nein.
Soziale-Jahres-Wohlfahrt?
Soziale-Jahres-Wohlfahrt
war gar nicht so weit weg.
Social Justice Warrior, okay!
Wiebke Schaff hat vor erst
einer Woche meinen Papa entdeckt.
Im Science of Music-Video.
Darf ich noch mal ganz kurz betonen,
wie knuffi eigentlich mein Papa ist.
Also ich glaub,
die Einlage ist am Ende
so ein bisschen untergegangen,
weil ich glaub nicht so viele Leute
die Endcard schauen,
deswegen hier noch mal bitteschön:
(singen) If you're schön schlau
and you know it - abonniert!
If you're schön schlau and
you know it - abonniert!
Dieser Rhythmus:
um tschyk, um tschyk, um tschyk!
Schön schlau and you know it...
Wusstet ihr außerdem,
dass mein Papa auch Chemiker ist?
Ohne ihn wäre ich
niemals Chemikerin geworden.
Naja, ich finde ja,
er sollte öfters mal
bei Videos vorbeischauen
oder da dabei sein.
Ich weiß nur noch nicht,
ob ich ihn überzeugen kann.
Wenn ihr auch dafür seid,
schreibt es unten rein.
Erik Bär sagt:
Gehieeern!
Heißt es nicht Gehieern?
Heißt es auf Hochdeutsch
vielleicht Gehirn?
So wie Vieeerzehn, das habe ich
auch erst letztens gelernt,
dass es nicht Vieeerzehn sondern
Vierzehn heißt - na ich weiß nicht.
Schreibt's in die Kommentare,
wie man Gehirn richtig ausspricht.
Wenn ihr Lust habt, können wir
sowas hier ab und an mal machen.
Natürlich nicht anstelle
des regulären Videos,
das ist heute, wie gesagt,
krankheitsbedingt eine Ausnahme.
Aber wenn ihr Bock habt,
sagt mir Bescheid,
können wir gerne noch mal machen.
Ansonsten, nächste Woche gibt's dann
wirklich Machiavellismus,
ihr dunklen Seelen,
euer warten hat dann ein Ende.
Also bis dann und bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)